I kept my son up way past his bedtime
last night to go and take him to see
that new spider-man movie spider-man
into the spider verse I think it's
called and my feelings about superhero
movies are well known I've been clear
about that
but my son is five years old and this
was the first that I'm aware of
the first PG rated spider-man film and
I've been waiting for something I've
been waiting for a superhero movie that
you could actually bring a five-year-old
to because I feel like it's a superhero
movie I mean five-year-old boys this is
this is what they're into so I couldn't
miss the opportunity to finally bring
him he's a huge huge spider-man fan he's
nuts about spider-man and I have to say
that my son he loved the movie I
actually found it mostly tolerable it
was unique visually anyway and it had
some entertaining entertaining moments
but the thing is I didn't realize that
spider-man dies in the first five
minutes of the movie and I that's not a
spoiler because it happens right away
and it's the catalyst for the plot so I
don't think I'm spoiling anything but he
does die right away he's he falls down
and then he's crushed by kingpin they
don't really show it but but still it
was traumatizing for my son who's a big
spider-man fan and he wasn't expecting
that I hadn't prepared him because I
didn't know that was gonna happen either
now spider-man is immediately replaced
by a bunch of other by a bunch of other
spider-man from other alternate
universes and also there's a new
spider-man in this universe but still my
son was deeply distressed and after
witnessing the death of spider-man and
you know I tried to explain to him on
the way home because he was so confused
I tried to explain to him oh no no well
well yeah that's spider-man die but he
was he was replaced by spider-man from
alternate universes don't you see five
year old would an alternate universe is
and he didn't in fact he was so
distressed that on the way home he said
to me he said daddy I don't think I want
to be spider-man when I grow up anymore
and it was the saddest moment as a
parent probably although when I asked
him why his his reasoning kind of made
sense because he explained
well being spider-man is dangerous also
you have to get up in the middle of the
night to fight bad guys and he said that
he needs to get his sleep so I couldn't
really argue with his reasoning but just
a warning to parents if you're taking
your kids to see that movie be prepared
to have a conversation about death and
parallel universes once it's over all
right
Tucker Carlson is once again in the
crosshairs liberals are pressuring
advertisers to boycott Carlson's show
because of comments that he made about
immigration so far I hop has pulled its
ad ancestry.com TD Ameritrade I think 9
8 or 9 others or more have also pulled
their ads now here's what I'm just gonna
read for you what Carlson said on his
show last week that got all of this
rolling and I'll put it in its context
he said our country's economy is
becoming more automated and tech
centered by the day it's obvious that we
need more scientists and skilled
engineers but that's not what we're
getting instead we're getting waves of
people with high school education or
less nice people no one doubts that but
as an economic matter this is insane
it's indefensible so nobody even tries
to defend it instead our leaders demand
that you shut up and accept this we have
a moral obligation to admit the world's
poor
they tell us even if it makes our own
country poorer and dirtier and more
divided now obviously it's that last
sentence that is has been the most
contentious and as far as the comments
themselves go his overall point is not
only right but unassailable that is
simply not economically feasible it is
indeed insane to continue importing
unskilled workers by the millions
especially as Carlson points out in an
economy a society where the workforce is
is more and more in need of people with
technical proficiency z' and skills and
we're getting the exact opposite so that
is a fine and important and completely
practical point to make and it's a point
that more people should be making but
Carlson says that immigration is making
our country poorer dirtier and more
divided well poorer and more divided
that that again is self-evidently true
it's when you bring in more poor people
you make the country poorer and as an
economic matter once again that's not a
smart move
more divided obviously it's making us
more divided in more ways than one
we're divided amongst ourselves about
the issue of immigration
not to mention culturally when you bring
people in with a different culture a
different language they don't assimilate
you have more divisions there so that
again is true so really this all boils
down to that one word dirtier
he said he's making the country dirtier
and I do think that that was a
gratuitous and unnecessary word to use
it's it's you can point out that many
immigrants are unskilled in terms of
their value to the marketplace but to
say that our country is dirtier because
of them well that obviously is
unnecessary it's beside the point that's
not that's that's not the point
true or not it's not the point and it
fits right into the stereotype anyway of
the bigoted conservative is going around
ranting about dirty foreigners it's like
it's like the it's it's it's a
stereotype that you're allowing yourself
to be to be tossed in with now granted
he has been misquoted here in some of
the headlines about this claiming that
Carlson called immigrants dirty he
didn't he didn't actually say that he
said that they make the country dirtier
that's not the same thing as saying the
immigrants themselves are dirty and he
has himself pointed out that he illegals
do leave behind a lot of trash at the
border and so forth so that's a problem
but still there's no reason to say
dirtiness is not the point it has
nothing to do with the point that
Carlson himself was making and the point
he was making was a good point about the
strain on the economy so he distracted
from his own point which isn't a good
idea especially when the point is so
important the other thing that I wish
that prominent conservatives would keep
in mind is that when you say stuff like
that when you say anything right
and you're a prominent conservative with
a lot of fans there's always going to be
a group of other conservatives of you
know your fans who may be the and the
sort that the kinds who maybe don't
think for themselves quite as much who
are just going to reflexively defend
whatever you say and they're gonna
defend it in a far less nuanced and
sophisticated way than you originally
presented the view so now we have to
endure the spectacle of some
conservatives not a lot with some
conservatives on social media standing
up and saying no he's right immigrants
are dirty it's time someone said it yes
it it's not the point this is this is
that's not the direction we need to go
with this guy we don't need to have a
conversation about how dirty the
immigrants make the country it's not the
point it completely detracts from the
important point that we're trying to
make so I wish he hadn't said that
however it is also stupid and gratuitous
and unnecessary to organize advertisers
advertiser boycotts over one word that
you didn't like and that perhaps was
poorly chosen if you disagree with
Tucker Carlson on this issue if you
disagree with his comments then why
can't you simply disagree just just say
you disagree that's all use your words
that's what I tell my kids use your
words I say it all the time
speak up and explain when I you know
when I hear the twins screaming at each
other and I go downstairs and my
daughter's screaming at my son I say I
say what do you use your what you don't
need to scream just use your words what
are you upset about use your words
right engage have a debate not
everything has to be a reason for
boycotts
so rather than boycotting you could just
say something like this you could say
Tucker Carlson was wrong to say what he
said because and
then fill-in-the-blank explain why he
was wrong that's how adults handle these
kinds of situations or at least it's how
they used to you're never going to win
an argument with a boycott it will never
happen all the boycott will do is cause
the other side to dig in and entrench
itself and ignore whatever you're saying
now I know someone might point out that
while these boycotts have nothing to do
with winning an argument that's not the
point the point is just to shut down the
opposing view not to engage with it and
I agree that that is of course the point
but it's not even effective in that
regard it's not even effective even if
you even if you're the kind of person
who would rather shut down the opposing
side than engage with it
boycotts still are gonna be
counterproductive for you so if you're a
proponent of unchecked immigration from
the third world and you want to shut the
other side up and not engage with it
rather than actually discuss the issue
with them um you aren't going to shut
them up by boycotting and trying to
silence them you only embolden encourage
rile up that's all you do so whatever
your objective is boycott culture
ultimately will detract from it I think
in the end whether you like it or not
and a lot of people obviously don't like
it but in the end you are left with only
one truly effective option and that is
to mete out to meet out on the
battlefield of ideas and to fight the
battle intellectually with ideas and
arguments and simply to present your
case I think in the end that's the only
choice that any of us actually have it's
the only effective way so if you think
that Tucker Carlson or anyone else is
wrong about immigration you can you can
you know kind of vent your frustrations
by boycotting and doing all this trying
to get your vengeance on him but you're
not gonna win the argument that way even
if you succeeded in getting Tucker
Carlson fired and getting rid of him
he's just gonna be replaced by someone
else with the same point of view so it's
just not gonna happen if you are a fan
of unchecked immigration from the third
world
eventually you're really you're going to
have to make your case and that's
actually the point the ultimate point
that Carlson was making there and it was
such a good point that's why I was so
frustrated they had to throw in the
dirtier line like because he made the
point that in terms of economic nobody
is will only on the other side of this
debate nobody is willing to actually
stand up and defend this economically
they don't even try so instead they look
for other things they want to label you
a bigot they want to do this and that
because they can't defend it extra
economically they can't defend it
intellectually and I can't even
pronounce the word intellectually so
what does that say about me
so one way you just this is what I say
to people on the left eventually you're
going to have eventually you're really
gonna have to make an argument here when
it comes to immigration and pretty much
any other issue you're going to have to
eventually actually make your case this
this strategy of trying to punish the
other side it isn't going to work
forever diminishing what you're getting
some diminishing returns on it and I
think we're at the point now where it
just it just doesn't work at all now I
want to get now to a truly infuriating
story here a federal judge has ruled
that cops and schools have no duty to
protect children during a school
shooting or at any other point I I
assume yes that is that's what's
happening let me read a bit from the
Miami Herald it says a federal judge has
ruled the Broward schools and the
sheriff's office we're not responsible
for protecting students during the
shooting at Marjory Stoneman Douglas
high that liability the judge reasoned
only works with incarcerated prisoners
or others who are involuntary committed
not school children with the ability to
take care of themselves
with the ability to take care of
themselves as in quote according to a
motion filed last week by US District
Judge Beth Blume so you have to be a you
have to be a criminal in the custody of
the police in order to warrant their
protection but if you're just an
innocent child well then you you gotta
fend for yourself the sun-sentinel on
they reported that bloom dismissed a
suit filed by 15 unnamed students who
say they suffered psychological trauma
from the school shooting that killed 17
and injured another 17 in February the
lawsuit claimed the school district and
the Broward Sheriff's Office along with
former school resource officer Scott
Peterson and school campus monitor
Andrew Medina and former BSO captain gen
Jordan failed through action or inaction
to protect the students while at the
school
Blum wrote the claim arises from the
actions of of the shooter a third party
and not a state actor
thus the critical question the court
analyzes is whether defendants had a
constitutional duty to protect
plaintiffs from the actions of Cruz so
she's saying while Cruz look Cruz didn't
work for the state what do you want us
to do plaintiff suggests that the
essential nature of a public schools
role in control over its students
requires that schools provide protection
and safety for their students yes that
plaintiffs would seem to be correct
about that but not according to bloom
bloom says however the suggestion that
school attendance equates to the level
of custody implicating a constitutional
obligation to protect has been expressly
rejected by the Eleventh Circuit so
she's saying
yeah well students are in the custody of
the school but they're not so much in
the custody of the school that the
school should actually protect them from
being murdered by a school shooter that
that's what she's that's her ruling
essentially to to rephrase it slightly
slightly all right a few things here
number one that school resource officer
hit outside like a coward while children
were being gunned down if a police
officer stationed at a school has no
duty to protect the children of the
school what the hell is he doing there
if he doesn't have a duty to protect
them why is he there what function does
he serve why is he being paid is he just
decoration is he like decor is he
furniture what is he doing there if he
doesn't have a duty to protect these
kids then then what's the point
that police have no duty to protect
innocent kids as just perverse the
people of Broward County were paying
that cops salary so he damn well had a
duty to them you can't take money from
the public under under the guise of
protecting and serving the public and
then claim you have no duty to protect
and serve them it's madness now I
understand it's true that courts have
ruled several times in the past in a
similar way finding that cops have no
legal duty to protect civilians so this
is not the first ruling you know in this
vein and I find all of those rulings
insane for the reasons stated above that
you are being paid by the public to
protect them that's why you're being
paid but we could even put those other
cases to the side for a minute we could
say well they're extenuating
circumstances
so on and so forth the what we're
dealing with here is even is is
different or it should be different
because Peterson was not just any cop
okay
he was stationed at the school he was a
school resource officer his whole job
was to be at that school to ensure the
safety of the kids who go to the school
so if you want to tell me that Peterson
had no obligation to other people in the
community to like someone driving by or
someone in a building next door well I
would say that that's still crazy
because he's a cop but but that's even
different from telling me that he has he
doesn't even have an obligation to the
kids in the school he was being paid to
protect what it just makes no sense as
far as the schools go attendance is
mandatory at a public school if you
can't afford private school and you
aren't homeschooling you are legally
required to send your kids to public
school you could go to jail if you don't
send your kids to school if your kids
are are absent from school unexplained
absences for too many times or for
long you could be put in jail for that
so the schools stand there and they say
give us your kids you have to you must
you have no choice and now they claim
they have no duty at all to protect our
kids while they have them in their
custody after insisting under force of
law and penalty of imprisonment that we
should put them in their custody that
again is just madness the whole reason
why I support putting armed guards in
every public school in America although
now I don't even know if there's a point
because if the armed guards don't have
any duty to do their job then what's the
point but the whole reason why I have
previously endorsed that proposal is
that attendance in the school is
compelled the state forces you to send
your kids there and if they're gonna
force you to do that
they absolutely must provide a safe
environment you can't legally compel me
to hand my kids over to you if you're
not gonna recognize your duty to protect
them well you can I guess apparently but
that's not how it should be duty and
obligation these are not supposed to be
a one-way street in America it's not
supposed to be that I as a civilian have
a duty to obey police and have a duty to
send my kids to school yet the police
and the school have no duty to me
whatsoever or to my children that's not
that's how things work in a dictatorship
okay
that's how things work in countries that
are undemocratic and are not free that's
not how it's supposed to work in a free
Republic
it's not supposed to be a one-way street
you can't tell me that I have a duty to
police I have a duty to law enforcement
they have no duty to me I have a tie I
am obligated to send my kids to school
but they have no obligations to me at
all it's crazy but it all under
scores a point that I think is a really
important point yeah
if nope nobody has an obligation to
protect you apparently even the ones who
ostensibly are being paid being paid to
protect and serve or even the people
even the people who demand that you hand
their kids over to them they don't even
have a duty to protect your kids
apparently so this is why the Second
Amendment is important because you
really are you're on your own when it
comes down when it comes down to it
you're on your own when push comes to
shove you can't rely on anybody else and
you've got to be able to protect
yourself and protect your family
now obviously the Second Amendment when
it comes to public school that's that's
not going to be much help because you
can't follow your own kid around in
school with a gun and you can't send
your kids to school with a gun so
unfortunately when it comes to the
public school the Second Amendment is
basically irrelevant
but beyond that in your everyday life
and at your home I think the point is
being made extremely clear here that you
need to have the ability to protect
yourself you cannot rely on the
government to do it even though people
who are not a fan of guns people who are
not supporters of a gun rights what they
tell you is well you know that's you
don't need a gun just call the police
okay well you can call the police and
hopefully the police will come but the
police have no apparently no obligation
to show up they have no obligation to do
anything for you so you've got to have
that ability yourself if that was not
already clear to you it should be now
one last thing as we gear up
miss and I'm wearing my as you can see
my beautiful Christmas sweater made
Christmas great in grant great again
although Christmas was always great of
course I want to I feel it's worth
saying something as we are just a few
days before Christmas and I was think
about this this week that there are a
lot of underrated perks of marriage
benefits that aren't discussed very
often and I think that some of these
underrated benefits and perks of
marriage the reason why they aren't
discussed is because they're kind of
one-sided in favor of either the wife or
the husband so nobody wants to talk
about them because it might alert the
other side to the iniquity here but I
have to mention it anyway because just
because it's so wonderful all right
here's the thing men if you get married
you will never have to go Christmas
shopping again it's great okay it is the
holidays are wonderful because I can
remember I remember when I lived alone
as a bachelor for five years and
Christmastime rolled around and my
family wasn't as big back then I didn't
have as many in-laws I didn't have as
many nieces and nephews now I'm up to
like I think we have like 18 nieces and
nephews now I've lost count although I
don't need to keep track anymore that's
the point but back then I didn't have as
big of a I felt a big family though and
it was up to me as a single individual
to buy Christmas presents for everyone
in the family and so I was like that
stereotypical man running around the
mall 30 minutes before closing on
Christmas Eve trying to do all my
Christmas shopping right then and there
I had no idea what I was doing I didn't
know what to get anyone I didn't know
what anyone wanted I was clueless and
then I got married and now my wife does
all the Christmas shopping all I have to
do is get her I just have to take care
of her I got to get her gifts right but
she does everything else and she's great
at it and she will
she likes shopping she she's a she's
like some kind of Christmas shopping
guru she she buys meaningfully she buys
meaningful gifts creative gifts she gets
people things that they want without
even looking at a list she just kind of
like knows what they want and she buys
it for them I don't understand it but
that's what she does she'll even be
she'll be out at a store or something in
in June and she'll see something and
she'll say oh that would be a great
Christmas gift for so-and-so and then
she'll buy it right there on the spot in
June it's it's incredible and then by
the time it's December first she's done
all the Christmas shopping and then
there's also the added excitement as a
man on Christmas when people are opening
their gifts and I get to find out what I
got everybody and then when they come up
to me and they say oh thank you I always
say something like I'll say I'll say oh
you're welcome you know I'm glad you
like that one I thought I thought it was
your taste so that's why you know I'm
glad you like it now I think they know
the truth and the every one of my family
knows that my wife does all the shopping
because the gifts are way too thoughtful
to have come from me but still I'm
telling you guys Christmas is if you
want it if you want to make Christmas
great again get married and Christmas is
a breeze you don't have to worry about
Christmas shopping at all
I do contribute some so I don't want you
to think I'm some kind of lazy oaf and I
don't contribute
we usually get bottles of bourbon for
various men in the family for Christmas
and so my wife will set me out to go buy
the bourbon and it's a it's a it's a
huge sacrifice that I have to make
honestly you know it takes me I mean it
takes me upwards of 15 minutes to go to
the liquor store and buy bourbon for a
few of the men in the family it's a but
it's a cross that I bear and I try to
have the right heart about it because
it's it's the holidays so get married
that's that's the moral of the story I'm
I think there are better reasons that
you know don't only get married for that
reason but it's at least a it's a I
don't know I think it's a top 20 reason
at least
all right I'll talk to you guys tomorrow
Godspeed